and is doing a tilting a massive tilt  here from Duda he looks like he just  wants the day to be done yeah he wants  it to be over and actually in that game  Wesley had a winning Advantage as black  after eight moves and uh Wesley he's  played it slightly safe over the last  few turns which is understandable only  needing a draw but Duda not enjoying  life right now and I think we've all had  this feeling at some point in our chess  careers sometimes things just go against  you your opponent's playing great you're  blundering and  yeah that's life apparently he's been  sitting like this for three minutes dude  I lost the match yesterday and uh  against Prague today it's not looking  good for him and tomorrow he faces make  Magnus Carlsen on the final day of the  tour finals Prague down on that he